[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
I hope everybody's
having a great week.
If we haven't met yet,
I'm Rachael Dempsey. I lead our
pro community at Posit.
And so this is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
everyone's facing,
and getting to hear what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
And if this is your first
time here or if you're watching this
recording at some
point in the future,
we're here every Thursday at
the same time, same place.
I should start saying now,
we are going to take a
little break for July
for a little summer
vacation time.
And there's a lot
of people traveling.
But normally, we are every
Thursday, same time, same place.
So together,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody.
We love hearing from you all
no matter your level of experience
or industry or area of work.
And so it's totally OK to
just listen in here, too.
But you can also jump
in the conversation and ask questions
or provide your own perspective on
certain topics in a variety of ways.
So you could jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
in the Zoom Chat.
And feel free to put a
little star next to it, of course,
if you want me to
read it instead
if you're in a coffee
shop or something.
And then we also have a slide
a link where you can ask
questions anonymously, too.
And so this will be
very important today,
because we are doing things
a little bit different here.
So
if you were on a few--
maybe this was a few months
ago now, where we had a
random opening, because one of
our featured leaders was sick.
We realized that we really
liked this occasional format of
us all being able to just
jump in and be the featured leader.
So we are all the
featured leaders today.
And so I wanted to also
point out that because of that,
if you wouldn't mind, when you
do jump in or ask a question,
to just introduce
yourself again, too.
I know some of us know
each other pretty well now from
coming to the Hangouts,
so it might be nice to
just do some introductions again to
when you jump in and ask a question.
But I can kick things off here with
something I'd love to ask you all about.
And this is something that's come
up in a few conversations from with
people who have reached
out on LinkedIn.
A lot of times, we'll feature
different leaders here that are
from larger companies, who have
established data science teams. And
at the same time,
there's a lot of people who
might be in the audience who
are building up a data team
for the very first time.
And I was just curious to kind of
open the discussion up with that to learn
from you all who are in that
position of building up a data science team,
what does that process
look like for you,
and how might that be different
than working in one of these
large Fortune 500
organizations?
And again, feel free to just
raise your hand on Zoom or
comment in the chat here, too.
Anybody like in the process of
just like starting to build up
a data science team or
you're thinking about
building one?
- Hey, Rachael. This is George.
- Hey, George.
- Hey, yeah. This is actually
like the perfect question
for me, because I started a
job about a month ago. And
first data scientist in HR
as brand new role, and so
kind of tasked with
starting from scratch with everything.
So building out
metrics, defining like--
defining metrics and
doing data governance,
learning a new system in HR.
There's the HRIS like the
main source. And then from there,
like developing a team.
So it's like,
starting from even
before I think what
you were talking about,
which is like starting
with the team,
it's like even before
that, which is--
but having the mindset of like,
this will turn into that. So
I think right now
it's like just
looking at the different
tools that are out there,
understanding how
we might manage a data lake
and trying to find the right--
I think right now we're
just looking at tools
and focused on that.
- Yeah.
How do you approach that like
knowing what to focus on first?
- So far, my approach has been
to have discussions with our HR managers.
So those are the primary
stakeholders are the ones that
are going to be
leveraging the data
and communicating it to either
higher up or to the different
managers within
the organization.
And also thinking about
security, and because with HR
data, it's highly
secure
information that we share.
We don't always want
to share demographics.
So also thinking about
security policies.
But just a lot of--
yeah, just a lot of
conversations with people
about what their
business needs are.
- Definitely. I see--
I'm just looking over to the
chat here, too. I see Eugene,
you had a few thoughts
on this topic.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Sure. I'll say, hi.
I had to build a team
at a previous position.
I'm currently a team
of one and, hopefully,
will be building a team soon.
I think
there are very few unicorns,
which I put three
things up there like--
there's a use case
and a necessity.
Sometimes,
you need somebody to be able
to build things as fast as possible.
So you've got to go for a
programmer or people who really
programming, who can
build a pipeline,
who feel they
understand production level stuff,
have dabbled in multiple
tools, et cetera, et cetera.
I can't necessarily rely on somebody
like that to be the math genius,
someone who understands
integration and probability
distributions and difference
between a poisson and an
exponential and la, la, la.
That person also
has a lot of value,
and everyone can learn
from them, too. And sometimes,
if you're in a place where
you need very sophisticated
modeling to take a leap up,
you need a person
like that probably,
who can bring in
that extra skill set.
And then there's the
contextual experts.
And I'm currently in a position
where I am not a contextual expert.
I am in bioinformatics,
which is my first foray into
the medical field of data. It is--
the data is more disgusting
in the medical field than pretty
much anywhere I've
ever seen, by the way.
But the
contextual expert probably in this
role is more important than anyone,
because they're going to be
spending a lot of time trying
to figure out, is
this a generic drug?
Or is this a name of a brand?
Or what is an encounter?
Why is this all
event level data
and not something where it's at
a patient level where I can do
my analytics? How do I
convert things from patient level to--
or from event level
to patient level?
A contextual expert
would be very,
very probably the most useful person
I would dive in on if I
had to hire someone in
a data science position
underneath me
in a team in bioinformatics.
So to me, the first
question is really like,
what are going to
be the highest impact projects?
And who of those three major
skill sets would I dive in on
to try and at least
create a my first employee
and then round out based
on their weaknesses? But I would
aim for trying to cover
those three bases.
If you're really going to build
a whole team of four or five,
six people, you really need
people who are, in my opinion,
really good experts at each--
at one of those three things,
because it's very rare to find
somebody who's an expert in all
three. And you'd be paying out
a ton of money if you do
find someone who's an expert in all three.
-
I think that kind of
answers your question you had asked
Libby, too. But do you want to ask
that to a few others here in the group?
- Sure. Yeah. That's the
experience that I have with
talking with people and
interviewing people,
interviewing with people,
is that when they
are building a team,
they're looking for somebody
to hit the ground running.
And they always use that term,
we need somebody to
hit the ground running.
And a lot of times what I
feel like they're saying is we need
somebody to do everything.
And we also need somebody
to tell us what to do,
because we don't
know what to do.
And that feels really scary,
because I often think,
well, I'm not that person.
I'm a stats person. I'm
applied stats person.
That's my side of the game.
I can't be everything for
everybody. So as a person who
is looking at the industry
that freaks me out,
it sounds like you guys are
also saying that person doesn't really exist.
And my
take on that is if
you have somebody who does everything
and knows everything,
they are now your single point
of failure. And if they leave,
something happens to them,
all of your expertise
goes in one person.
And instead of needing to
replace the one person who was
maybe a SME or maybe
the programming person,
you now have nothing. So
I'm curious about people's thoughts on
building a team
of people who are
lower level and
not those unicorns.
And how do you make that
work, what do you look for?
KATHERINE: Libby,
I can't figure out how to raise
my hand right now in Zoom.
- That's OK.
- I probably should
say that too. Yeah.
So if anybody looks at the
bottom where it says reactions,
there's like a
little Smiley face.
KATHERINE: Oh,
there it is. Yeah.
- Sorry, I should have put
that in there. But thanks,
Katherine, for jumping in.
KATHERINE: I was in full screen
and so that had gone away.
I feel like a lot of times,
looking for people who can
hit the ground running is like
corporate code for we are not going
to onboard you or train you at all.
And
that's really something that I
think when you are building a
data science team, like
they were talking about
before, you need to say,
these are the people that I
need and the skill sets that
they're going to have and
then build your onboarding around
what that team is
going to look like.
One of the things that we've
been doing is trying to get
away from, oh, well, this
one person knows everything.
And so like for six months,
all we did was write
documentation about our
processes and transcribe email
chains from three years ago
into things like that so that
when we do bring on new people,
we can onboard them not only
on the technical aspect of the job,
but also on the context
of the data especially because we're
in the medical field as well
where you are bringing on
people who may not have had
any medical experience before.
- Definitely.
Thank you all for--
I'm trying to read through the
chat here for people who want
to comment on a
specific topic too.
Coulter, I see that you had
shared when I first said about
starting the first data
science team that you started
a data team. And I'm curious,
did you have to build
up the business case for that
or were you hired on to start
the data science team?
COULTER: Yeah. Hey, everyone.
Kind of almost both.
So I work for a local
government public health
department. And
it was essentially uncharted territory
when it comes to data
science. Everything is--
it was done in Excel. And I
think I kind of tried to get
buy-in on this from a selfish
point of view because I was
doing all this data
and I was like,
this shouldn't take this long.
We're spending a ton of
time trying to do all this.
So luckily, I had great
leadership that said, you know
what, that's right, we
should start something
and
was able to hire someone
and immediately just trying to
convert everything to R,
automate as many things as
possible. And I love--
I guess I'll preface
the next part--
I love hand-washing dishes because
the catharsis from it. And
the first time that we
were able to show someone, hey,
you know this thing that
used to take you 16 hours,
it takes 30 seconds now.
And the joy in their face--
I will never forget that.
And I think that really
showed leadership.
This is something worth
investing in even further.
So that was about 2
and 1/2 years ago.
And like I said, we were
able to hire one person to join.
And now we are a team of 8.
And it's been super awesome.
Everything, everybody's
already said,
has been bits and pieces in
our experience as well either from
security or just scaling, just
things in general. So it's been
fun. Still got a long way to
go, a lot of cool stuff to learn.
- That's awesome. You go from starting
the team to eight now. How did you
figure out what those
roles should be,
those eight people?
COULTER: Oh, great question. I
originally kind of designed it--
and someone had just
mentioned this--
as hey,
this person may be
focuses on specifically visualizations,
maybe pipelines that get to
a visualization, and then
realize, for continuity
of operation purposes,
that wasn't going
to be feasible.
So switch to a different method
of almost everybody is kind of
trained on everything and can
kind of do stuff if needed.
But no one is really expected to
be an expert at every other person's job
because that's asking
a lot from people and
as a leader,
I don't think anyone should
expect every person on the team
to be the expert at everything.
- Absolutely. I wanted to
remind everybody to, if you
feel OK or comfortable with
it, just introducing yourself too,
especially for people who are joining us
for the first time here as well.
OK, let me double check.
And Curtis and Hannah are
helping me organize questions.
But anybody else want to
comment on this topic too?
Oh, Alan, I see your hand.
Did we lose Alan?
Alan, can you hear us?
- I can see you talking,
Alan. But no sound.
- Come back to Alan.
Anybody else have thoughts on this,
building up your first data team?
- Is that better?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Yep, there you are.
- OK.
You turn on your computer
one day and it's like,
I don't have a
microphone. [INAUDIBLE]
is a microphone.
What was I going to talk about?
I think so sort of working
on the whole sort of circuit from
what Libby was
saying to [INAUDIBLE]
Katherine to Coulter--
I was thinking about it.
I think I've had a really
interesting experience
with my team of
saying for a number of years,
we need cross supportability for
the things that we're doing
and finding that as the
team grows, just the demand grows.
We have more stakeholder teams
that we're connected with and
people end up being kind of
de facto kind of drawn with dotted
lines to those stakeholder
teams and getting kind of
specialized in those lanes versus
being able to sort of
share and cross support.
And that's been a
real challenge because
for years, I've wanted to help
certain folks who support really high
intensity stuff to have more help.
And I think probably I've had
a combination of really good luck
getting good people on the team
who come in and are eager to
help to do that.
But I think we hit a little bit
of a critical mass with the team where
there were enough people--
and the team is now 6--
and I have enough people who
are curious and who are skilled
who can help without getting
sort of completely pulled into
the pool of being
able to cross support.
And so whether it's
disciplinary or subject matter expertise,
I really have felt
like in the last year,
there's been a tipping point of
my team is big enough now that
they can help one another whereas
when it was two, they were just
head down focused on
getting stuff done.
And then when it was four,
there was a little more
room but still pretty head down.
And now with six,
there's enough of a cohesive
team there that they can share,
they can collaborate without
me driving all of the
collaboration.
It feels like that size has
really opened up a bunch of new
opportunity that I don't think
I could have created with two
or three or four people.
And it's got a whole new set of
working
and meeting challenges.
But their ability to run has
really taken off in such a cool
way in the last six months as
they've kind of got up to speed
with one another.
So I don't know
if that leads to
a concluding point,
but it's been really neat
to see that transition over time
as the team has grown.
And they've gotten to know one
another, develop their skills,
and develop their
subject matter expertise.
It's been really,
really fun and rewarding to see
them get good at what they do
and get really good at
helping one another. It's really cool.
- That's great.
Thank you, Alan.
Katherine, I see your hand
raised. Do you want to jump in?
KATHERINE: Yeah, I love that
from Alan because that sort of
collaborative work really facilitates the
rest of the data science.
It's something that I've
struggled with is making sure
that people get credit for
doing that where it frequently becomes
unseen work. You're not
emailing a spreadsheet to
someone, you're not
doing that, but fostering
that relationship,
being active in your chat,
sending out those
emails to those teams,
building a business use
case around something
is so important to staying connected
to the rest of those teams.
And so we have a strategy
for getting credit for that.
But if anyone else has
anything where how do you, one,
manage that unseen work but
also make sure that the people
who are doing it still
get credit for it,
I'd love to hear about that.
- Can I ask you, Katherine,
what's your team strategy for that?
KATHERINE: We do something
every quarter called
Take a Bow where we basically
have our members write up,
and they do it in
an hour markdown,
but they write up everything
that they think that they did
throughout the quarter.
And then they send that to
me and my sister team manager. And
we aggregate that information
and we escalate it up our
reporting pipeline.
So it's got the hard details
of the stuff that we did--
here's the GitLab repo,
here's the business value that
this created, et cetera. But also,
I did all of these other
things like I was active on my
committee board--
anything else that you're a part
of that want to make sure
that you get credit for,
you can escalate that.
So I did kind of like
outsource the management of that credit.
But it still makes sure that
it's at least seen by like
one and two levels above
the person who's doing that work.
But it's a lot of manual stuff.
- Yeah.
Somebody had
recommended to me in the
R Ladies Slack Group to
like every week, send yourself an
email of all of the things that
you did that week. So then at
the end of the year or
whenever you're showing
your leadership
team what you did,
you remember all
those little things.
And I think a lot of what
I do is sometimes that glue work
that I sometimes
forget like, oh,
that was really important that
I did that and I connected
these teams across the company.
But if I didn't write it
down for myself, I wouldn't
maybe have remembered it or
thought it was as important.
Any other thoughts on what
other teams are doing to kind
of highlight some of that work?
I see Aaron.
You had a comment
in the chat here.
Oh, yeah, around
annual review time.
OK, Mark, I'm curious,
what's your team's process?
- Sorry, I was on mute.
Yeah, Aaron said
in the chat that she
keeps a one note open.
My team--
I work for a health care system
in Houston on a group of analysts.
We're really small. We have like
four of us on the team.
So we're really tight knit,
but we all have our
little domain area of expertise.
But we all do
something similar.
The only difference is we
all share that same one note
that our manager
sees and we keep
track of with
weekly one on ones.
So it's a really good way
to just see across the year what
you're working on and then look
back and see what you've accomplished.
- Definitely. I see
Jeffrey had asked a great
question in the chat.
I know you don't have a mic
at the moment. So I'll read it.
But the question was
at what point and how do
you decide to stop focusing on the
non-analytics work that has
filled your backlog and push
for more of the
advanced analytics.
A lot of our issue is
requests come in and they are dashboards
that should be done by more
of a business analyst and not a
data engineer or data
scientist. But for us,
it's difficult to dig out of
that hole or find a stopping point.
I see a few
comments here in the
thread of that. So I'll
start with you, Jared,
if you feel like
jumping in here.
And sorry if I'm--
JARED: Hey, Rachel.
Can you hear me?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Oh,
there you are. Yes.
JARED: Sorry about that.
- No worries.
JARED: Yeah, no,
I think it's just kind of
like he was talking about further
down like chicken
or egg. If you're
getting to the point where
the workload in the backlog is
just becoming insurmountable, how do you
do a more efficient job of
organizing and kind of
disseminating that to push the
needle forward instead of
just kind of being drowned out
of the work? So do you take
the approach of trying to
split the work and split the
idea of having a focus on
analytics versus
non-analytics teams or
are you trying to hire more
of those unicorns that can do both
sides of that to help and
how do you manage
your approach that?
I think that's the big question
for me anyway. [LAUGHS]
-
I thought something that was
interesting on the topic of
dashboards is I think it was--
I'm blanking on
who had said this--
but if you stopped creating
any of those dashboards,
which ones would
people really notice
that were missing and which
ones are we just creating for
the sake of creating
them and updating them.
KATHERINE:
I was remembering that too from
a couple of weeks ago and even
going back to Libby's comment
in the chat of like what's
going to happen if
you don't do that.
And if the answer is
$4 billion of critical
business processes stop,
then they probably need to
hire someone to make that dashboard.
And if the answer is one
guy gets a little upset,
then maybe you don't make it.
- Exactly.
Jonathan,
Remmers, or Chris,
I see you had some
thoughts on this topic too.
Do you want to jump in here?
Let see if anybody unmutes.
- I was saying that I
get frustrated because
descriptive analytics
has a bad name now.
Nobody wants to come into
our field to do descriptive
analytics or reporting. But
it's actually still very important.
And
you just can
encourage yourself.
If the descriptive stuff you're
doing is very important, it's OK.
And it's not always easy
to put together either.
But if you're trying
to make that switch,
you may have to first
convince people of the value.
Not just say, oh, we want
to do advanced analytics.
They don't understand
what that means.
But what's the outcome
that you want to achieve
that you need to go do
advanced analytics to get to.
And some of what I've
done internally is talking to
stakeholders in the company
what are their goals,
what do they want to know,
what are questions that
they haven't asked,
what are questions they
don't ask because
they don't want to be
disappointed that there's not an answer.
So I will ask people to
think without any restrictions.
Don't worry about what
we can or can't do.
What would you like to see?
And then if you can get people
who would sponsor, yeah,
these are the outcomes
we would like to get,
then you have a little
more weight behind that request to
try to shift your time away
from descriptive analytics to something else.
- Thank you.
Gerard, I see you have
your hand raised here too.
You want to jump
in on this topic?
- Yeah, I think what
you just said is
critical because
getting access to the data is usually
one of the harder things to do.
So if you have an executive who
wants a report or a dashboard or whatever,
you can break that
deadlock in getting access to the
data. And once you have it,
you can do the more advanced
analytics and start to build that
business case of if we look at
it this way, if we do more,
we can give you more value.
But in the end,
getting that data and breaking up
that process of getting the data,
processing it and analyzing
it in three different steps--
it helps in a
variety of things.
It helps in building your
team slowly because those are
sometimes three different expertises.
And you can potentially
give the getting the data to IT so
that you don't have to do it. So
it
opens up time for
your own analysis.
It also makes it easier to go
all the way to the beginning of
the discussion about
hitting the ground running.
You have
people who are good at these
three different things.
And I think when they describe
that they're looking for people
who are hitting the ground
running, are people that
can answer that final question,
that give that report to
the executive and give
that final result.
So if you can use that
from a report, from a
straightforward dashboard,
if you can use that
to break the deadlocking and getting
access to the data and
start slowly building some analytics,
I think that's a
good way to start.
You have to be
very careful that,
to also what
people were saying,
that it doesn't become your
day job and your only day job.
-
Can I just confirm with anybody
here what is descriptive
analytics exactly mean
or advanced analytics?
KATHERINE: I kind of view--
- I was thinking that there's
this classic three or four step thing.
It's like you have descriptive
and then diagnostic and then
predictive and
then prescriptive.
That was like
something maybe
8, 10 years ago
that made the rounds.
KATHERINE: I've seen
that too, Chris.
- I think people, when
they say analytics,
they're talking about
everything to the right of
descriptive on that visual.
- OK.
- Descriptive is like what
is going on right now,
how many of something.
KATHERINE: --this is what
is happening or has happened.
But diagnostic is kind of
like what has happened.
I think it's just, yeah,
this is what it is.
- Cool. Thank you.
KATHERINE: And you can make
a bar graph of, I think,
counts as descriptive
analytics.
- Ralph, I see your
hands raised here.
JARED: By the way,
you just can't do any of
those other three things good at all
if you don't do
descriptive analytics.
-
What I found with working
with clients is helpful is I
actually made an image of
a pyramid where the first layer
is descriptive analytics, and
then predictive is smaller,
and then prescriptive
is on the top.
And so with the idea that
majority of your time running
your business and most of your
efforts as a data team should
be in that descriptive side
because that's the basis of
anything to predict the future
or making large changes in your
business. So that's
been helpful.
And then I also started
adding a basement of data management.
- Yeah, I was going to say,
there's a data quality
layer under there somewhere.
-
I call it the basement even though
I don't know if pyramids have basements.
- That's great. George,
I see your hands raised.
- Oh, yeah. I just wanted
to chime in on the descriptive.
Yeah, to kind of reinforce
what was said about--
it's just as important
and crucial and fundamental.
And it made me think of--
actually, this morning, I cracked
open my Edward Tufte book
and just
in awe over the descriptive
stats that are in there.
But the way that
they're presented--
they're presented
in a way that solves a
problem. There's the classic
cholera outbreak
map that was done.
And it's like,
that's descriptive analytics,
but it's just in a way
that's telling a story.
It's in a way that
resonates with people.
So it's not necessarily
like, oh, it's just so simple
and maybe not
worth our time.
But it's more like
how do you convey those
descriptive stats.
It could be as simple
as a bar chart.
But is that really
answering the question,
is that really getting to--
it could be it could
be descriptive stats.
That's all they need. But
again, how it's conveyed is
vital.
- Definitely. Thank you.
I'm loving this
lively discussion here. Mike,
I see your hand raised.
- Hi, yeah.
I was just going to say that
I heard a great talk from
a data science leader I think
working for one of the big
supermarkets in the UK who
describe descriptive analytics
as kind of looking in
the rear view mirror.
So what has happened.
So maybe that's
also quite a good analogy.
- So do people generally use
BI tools for more of descriptive analytics
and predictive
or whatever is past
that is more of--
KATHERINE:
I still use orange ggplot
plot for all of my descriptive
analytics. But Power BI
is really powerful too.
JARED: They will usually
rely on business analysts
to produce dashboards
of descriptive statistics.
But it doesn't necessarily ever
imply that you're going to get
that extra layer of context as to
maybe why those stories are taking place.
- I see on the topic
of like getting rid of some dashboards,
Mark, you had a great
question earlier.
Do you want to jump in here?
- I think he had to run out.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Oh, OK. Well,
the question was,
does anyone have experience
or suggestions for getting folks
to agree to
deleting dashboards.
Mark said, our group
has so many dashboards.
We maintain with only slightly different
views of the same data set.
And I have thus far been
unable to get buy-in even though the
technical debt we've
incurred is astounding.
- I have a few
comments on this.
So I'm at Centene
along with Katherine
who's talked a
bit this morning.
We have 75,000 employees or so.
And I actually just helped
run a Hackathon for anyone that
wanted to participate
at the company. And
the whole purpose,
the whole problem statement
was effectively what can we do
about our dashboard
craze situation.
And believe it or not,
outside of this Hackathon,
since January 1st,
there have been about 25,000
dashboards that have been deleted.
So the idea is
what is going on with so
many dashboards and reports that are
now all on the cloud.
And so
yeah, it's a serious problem.
And I don't think that,
for larger
corporations at least,
I kind of feel like the
thought has been just create a
dashboard, if it's not used,
don't even really think about it.
Yeah, if we need to delete this
later, we can, no big deal.
But there's costs associated with
all this and the resources
that are used to just
keep those online.
So yeah,
this whole Hackathon was done to
really try and drill in on
can we put some strategy behind
a rationalization approach or
some kind of decommissioning
approach or strategy
to all these different
reports and dashboards
that the company has. And
I'm not just talking--
25,000 shiny apps would be
incredible. I'm talking more like
reports
and dashboards across
all of our platforms--
Power BI, Tableau,
MicroStrategy, et cetera.
- The Hackathon sounds
really cool too.
- Yeah, the winners
did an excellent job,
coming out with kind of a
solution that had more of that prescriptive
insights for leadership.
So I'm really excited to
see what we do about maybe
productionizing that as kind of
a Shiny app or something like
this for leadership to have
a clear visibility into how
many reports should
be on a decommissioning path or
et cetera. Yeah.
- [? Annas, ?]
I see your hands raised.
Do you want to jump in?
- Sure. So I guess
one gentle way to
test the waters for governance for
some of these dashboards is to--
if it gets updated on a
constant basis, try one period
to not update it or one month
not to update it and see what
reactions you get. And
if it's a live feed,
try to cut it off and see
what reactions you get.
Now if no one says anything
and they're not really paying
attention to it, then that's a
good sign. And you can say, OK,
this is probably not being used
as much as it should be
or as much as expected.
But obviously, if
you hear people
express their dissent and
say, no, we rely on this data,
then that's a good indicator to
say that the dashboard is still
relevant and
the stakeholders still need
it to be in place and active.
- Thank you.
I see
Abigail, you have your
hand raised here too.
You want to jump in next?
- Yeah. So we monitor
our usage of dashboards. I
mean, that's really the start.
Tableau was APIs--
I don't know what
other tools have.
But you can see who's
looking at your dashboards and when.
And so being able to go in
with like nobody's looked at this in
three months, that's a
really strong argument--
literally nobody's using
this. And even then,
nobody wanted anything deleted.
But
we were able to
get permission to
basically hide dashboards
nobody was using except for the
people who we're
actually building the dashboards,
write some documentation that says
what all the ones that are
in hibernation do.
So in the future,
somebody wants to bring it
back, they can read that and
say, oh, I needed this.
But it's not something that
we're having to worry about
maintaining on a regular basis.
- Do you think sometimes,
it's that the dashboard
or whatever visualization was
really helpful for someone
when they first saw it,
but then they don't know
where to ever find it again?
- No, because nobody's
looked at it in three months.
I think people just really get
freaked out by the idea that
somebody spent time working on
building this thing and you're
going to get rid of it.
And so we promise we're
not getting rid of it,
it will still exist
if you ever need it.
I think that's the safe
thing even though, really,
some of these are
never coming back.
- George, I see you have
your hand raised here too.
You want to jump in?
- Yeah, we actually did that
with the dashboard
because we actually--
it was a Power BI dashboard
and it tells you when--
it gives us reports
that no one's using it.
And so we decided to
stop updating it and found that
OK, they actually did need
it, but not as frequently.
And so I think just going
back to the requirements for
building it and understanding
the frequency of that.
And so just having a
discussion about what were the
expectations. So realizing, oh,
they really only need
like once a quarter.
But
we built it in a way that
could be done every day,
but we didn't need to
update the data every day.
So sometimes,
it's just understanding the
requirements and not
necessarily going to think,
well, they don't ever use
it. Well, when they use it,
it's super important.
It's just not frequent.
Yeah.
- Absolutely. I
see all this fun chat happening
during the hangout too.
And I am jealous I
don't get to read it.
But I'm going to read
that all after too.
I love to see the party
happening there. But there was
a Slido question someone had
asked anonymously. I try to
save code tips that I can
see uses for in later projects.
But I feel like it's so messy.
How do you all keep track
of frequently used code, notes, and tips?
And Marcos, I see your
hand raised here.
MARCOS: Sorry,
I didn't think you'd see it
in time before someone else start talking.
So I work in Python almost
exclusively at work.
And I think I
mentioned that before.
And we do a lot
of Jupyter Notebooks for interactive
things which I know people
have a lot of feelings about.
But I am determined to put as
much code as I can into GitHub.
So we have
GitHub repositories
for our main
production things that are
controlled. Our team has--
my big team, my big
pricing team has a
repository that's
basically scripts.
And some of the scripts
can be things that we run
automatically. But some
of them are just like--
it's just a repository
that anyone can push to.
And so if I write anything that
I think is cool and that I want
to use later and I think
anyone else will have any benefit of,
I will put it into a utility
scripts folder in there.
And it's version controlled and
I'll tell people about it
and then other people sometimes
will contribute to it.
And then I also have my
own little secret, private Marcos repo
where if something isn't quite
baked enough for to share with
everyone, I will save
it to my own repository.
And so version control
and GitHub, if you have
access to those tools,
are a really good way to not lose
stuff into some one off file or
some off off Jupyter Notebook or whatever.
And so my strategy is to write
as much as I can inside an
editor and save it
into a Git control
code file. And then if I
need to use it in a notebook,
I will import it into my
notebook which you can do with
Python pretty easily.
That I'm not exactly sure how
the other folks think about this
since I was there actually
when I was terrible at writing
functions. But
that's kind of my strategy.
And so if you haven't learned
about Git and version control, highly recommend
either chatting with
other folks here or
just trying to
learn more about it.
- Definitely.
One resources I know
is the happy Git with R
book, if anybody wanted to
share that in the chat. But
Eugene, I see you
had your hand raised.
EUGENE: Yeah. Functions,
functions, functions, functions--
just fictionalize it, give it
a descriptive name, put it in
somewhere that I created
a company R repo
or R package.
Just titled it the company
name. Everybody had a copy of
it, everybody could make edits,
everybody could
update those edits,
and every single function was--
it just became more and
more generalized which is the best
thing about writing functions
and forcing that everybody
writes functions.
And you can't finish writing
your function unless you
actually create a manual page,
which is the best part about
it. So I know it takes an
extra 10 minutes and it's such a hassle
to add that three
sentences of documentation that described
the arguments and what
you want to use it for.
But I mean,
the overall build of
productivity over time is just--
nobody has to resolve
the same problems.
We all have to convert dates,
we all have to convert zip
codes, we all have
to add leading zeros,
we all convert things from
factors to strings or strings
to factors, et cetera,
count the number of factors.
Just build functions
that do this stuff.
Just build them and
leave them there.
And any time anybody
has a problem like this,
in your team meeting,
you say, hey,
what new functions were
added this past week.
It's very simple to
get that sort of--
it's exponential productivity that
you'll get across the team.
- Do we need a Data
Science Hangout GitHub and packages? [LAUGHS]
Katherine, I see your
hand raised here.
KATHERINE: Yeah, I was just
going to comment that even
if you're not on
a full data science team
in an organization that has GitLab
and R professional tools--
before I was at Centene,
I was the only R user and a
data science team of one. And I
basically made a setup script for
myself that had some of my
most helpful functions in it. And
in my little profile, I said,
put all these in my
session at startup.
And so it was.
It was a function for dealing
with dates in the format that I
knew that they came from
my database and things like that.
Even if you're just doing it
for you, it's still a good practice.
And then if you do onboard
more people and you start sharing--
you can share that script
with them and then eventually make
that business case like, hey,
we do need a GitLab license
so that we can share these things
as our team grows and as
our organization grows.
And if it does
still just be you,
you've made your
own life better.
- Of course, yeah.
Thank you all for the
thoughts here too.
Before leaving this topic,
I was kind of reminding
myself--
I think Mike Smith,
you talked about this
by using snippets too?
- Yeah,
snippets are fabulous
because you can give
a little shortcut
and then it gives you
a skeleton or a framework
where you can jump into
certain parts within that framework and
kind of almost also
complete certain sections.
You can share snippets.
There's use this
has a way of opening up the
snippet so that you can edit them.
So for things that you
do frequently and where you
actually have that framework,
they're really, really helpful.
But I think I'm leaning
more towards what's just been said
about write functions
because it's like you can
also then document those, test them,
you can roll them
up into a package.
- For some reason,
writing a function
just sounds scarier to
me than the word snippet.
- Well,
it does because writing a
function implies that you're
going to write
the documentation,
then you're going to
maintain it forever,
whereas a snippet--
well, it's a bit
more throwaway.
- Yeah, I think just a
point to add to this--
this is something that I tried
to do in my company is also
sharing that you've
done this with others,
making sure it's on
your knowledge based solution
because then you find out, oh,
this has already been
done by somebody else,
and I didn't have to put all
this effort if they'd only share it.
So I think contributing to
the community is important
internally just as well
as it is externally.
- I see there was a question.
Ezra, you had asked,
is there a place that
Posit shares functions created by
the community.
And Curtis, you had
some thoughts there.
Do you want to jump in?
Curtis, I'm putting you
on the spot there. Sorry,
I just thought you had
commented on there.
- I was kind of half
joking, trying to do it lighthearted.
But that's usually what package
is and trust to GitHub repos
are for. But I see the point.
There's this kind of middle
ground or lower ground
with a cookbook type thing.
So the first book I ever
bought related to R was the Ggplot2
Cookbook which is
literally just a collection of
great tips for ggplot2. So
I totally see the value.
- Let me go back to see
some questions we maybe
had missed.
Libby, I saw earlier you
had a question around collaboration.
Do you want ask that one?
- It was probably about time.
There's a conversation around
we really want people to
collaborate and how do we get
them to talk to each other and
how do we get them to
form a community and be more connected
because we're all remote.
And my question is,
do they have the time to
do that because if they don't,
you are expecting something magical.
It's not going to happen.
And so the push that
I am trying to go
for is prioritize
timing, prioritize chunks of
people's time for that stuff.
If you don't tell them to do
it and that you want them to do
it, give them the
time to do it.
It's probably not going to happen
because they're going to be heads down
and feeling too pressured.
And I was thinking about
there is a Harvard Business
Review article that I read
recently about capacity, about how people
do their best work when
they're actually about 85%
capacity or 80%
capacity, not 100%. And
aiming for people
to be at 80% or 85%
does free them up a little
bit to have the mental and
emotional capacity to connect with
other human beings to share stuff.
And
we have all this double work
and we have all these silos.
Guess what? If people
talk to each other,
those walls start
to break down.
And you start to realize
other people are duplicating work.
what's possible because someone says,
oh, yeah I did that
in this other project.
And maybe it's not
the exact same thing,
but it's going to help. So
that's my two cents, I guess.
Less of the question, but
are you prioritizing your
people having that time.
- I love that.
Thank you, Libby.
And I think Mike has
some thoughts to share on it.
- Sorry, for being the guy
that jumps in here. But--
- You don't have to be sorry.
- I've been the R guy at
our company for many, many, many years.
And before we really go
our R community going,
everyone came to me--
oh, Michael know the answer
to this, oh, Michael,
help me to solve out these
insulation issues, oh, Michael,
help me answer this tricky question I've
got about how to do this thing.
So and
that then funnels
everyone in through me.
And you might argue that
that's great for my brand.
But it's making me beyond 100%
capacity and it's hard to keep
up with all the request.
And it means that I have
the same question again and again
and again and again and again.
And it gets really tedious
because even though I bang up
to it and go, you
must do it this way,
everyone's so busy
and they're like this
and it never gets through.
Once we have the
community in place,
we have a single source of here's
the information and how to install R,
here's the information on how
to get the packages you need.
We have that place for the
written documentation, we have
our community sessions that
say, if anyone's got questions,
they come in through
that community page.
And anyone can
answer that question.
So
it's absolutely vital
that the community gets
going because otherwise,
it all funnels through your
regional local friendly R expert.
And that person just
winds up burning out.
So we've
been talking about the ROI
on taking time to build community.
But without it,
someone's going to burn out
because they're at the sharp
end of that funnel.
Sorry,
voices of experience and also
feeling thankful that my SWAT
team is there and we're
building community every day. So
make up the SWAT team.
- That's great. Yeah, big
kudos to the Pfizer team
there and all the different community
efforts you lead.
Gerard, I see your hand
went up on this topic.
- Yeah. So when COVID
hit and everybody started working from
home, what we did was--
I establish tee time
a couple of times a week for
the team to get together.
And there was a
very simple rule--
you were only asked to
talk about work-related things
in the last five minutes.
But it really helped to
have that interpersonal connection with
the people in the team.
And so you kind of knew if they
were stressed, if they were
doing something fun
at home or whatever.
And in of those last
couple of minutes,
you could quickly ask
what they were working on,
did anyone need any help,
do we need to make
any connections between different teams.
And so to
Libby's point, yeah,
if you don't force it,
those conversations don't happen. And
because the first couple
of weeks of COVID,
no one talked to each
other. Everybody was just doing work
and
that just didn't work.
So
after initiating that tea time
that at least that
forced conversation
really helped in multiple
ways, not just socially,
but also in keeping
that collaboration and that
networking going.
- I'm thinking about how
sometimes we've talked about
the power of
automating something that was once
manual and how that helps
you exponentially
down the road.
But it's almost the same
with the community efforts.
You need to take a chance to
step back and look at the big
picture and create that
community so that it can help
everybody later on down the
road and that you're not just
the one person who everybody's
going to for questions
and that there's so many
others that are supporting each other.
Eugene, I see your
hand is raised too.
- Yeah. I mean,
it's an interesting concept
that the documentation and the
building functions for a team and
having your team iterate on the functions.
I don't think people
recognize that that is its own
collaboration. It begins
literally the collaboration.
I remember when I was hired,
I really liked my
first management gig.
And I walked in on the bar
code that they were using and
everybody was on a different
version of R and everybody was
using different versions of
packages and everybody had
three or four different
templates to do basically a
similar version of the
exact same analysis.
Theirs worked for them,
they had certain functions that
had certain edits for them for
one of these particular
use cases. I mean,
it was terrible in terms
of overall productivity and
building models took
literally three days.
And it took me about
six months to a year.
But in a year,
I had people building models in
four hours instead of three days.
And we were all using the exact
same R version and we were all
using snippets of functions that
slowly got better because somebody finally
put one into a package.
And when somebody checked out
that function and actually did
something with it,
it broke for them because
they were using a slightly
alternative use case. So
what did we teach them to do?
You add a new argument.
And then having that new argument,
you add that to
the documentation.
And then on the bottom,
you have these edits.
You just add an
if/else statement
based on that new argument.
And now the function does
both things for both people.
And this literally began
the collaborative process.
And there were people who
took two years to finally check-in
their own brand new function
even though they were making
edits of functions in the meantime.
And it was a big, yay,
Amanda finally checked in
her first function, wohoo!
And the package grew and more
use cases were handled and our
entire library of
code got better
and our ability to
talk to each other--
hey, didn't you build
something that did that,
didn't you build something
that solved a similar problem.
And if it doesn't do the
exact same thing you do,
you get to be the unit
tester and figure out how it works.
And then you build
experience with Git.
Now your resume grows
because you have experience working
with repos, you have
experience working with version control,
you have experience modifying
functions, automating your work.
All these things are like--
you're solving the
calibration problem,
you're solving a productivity
problem, you're solving
the ability to actually
contribute and build the skill
sets that every future job is
going to need from you. I mean,
the whole thing is
literally like--
you can solve, in my opinion,
multiple problems just by
trying to centralize your code
and get everybody to
work together on similar code,
similar projects.
And it doesn't even
have to be similar.
But we're all data scientists and
we have to be like wild people,
sometimes writing SQL parsers.
And then suddenly, you can
talk to the database people,
and they build a scripting
function that builds a SQL
parser build SQL queries for
them with a few arguments. And
we had that experience of being
able to finally hand off SQL
queries or SQL query builders
to our own business analysts
that worked in SQL all day.
And yes, we used to R staple
all this text together and
build SQL queries and they were
just amazed. They
were like, oh,
this is how you guys get
that done so fast. Yes,
and you can do it too.
- I love that.
I love how passionate you are
about it, but also that, yes,
and you can do it too.
One last question
I wanted to ask.
I see Priyanka asked a question
that is kind of on the same
topic around making
time for community,
but for the team builders
and leaders here.
How do you encourage your
teams to keep upskilling while
continuing the
business as usual?
- I'm really lucky. I have
Sam Palmer on the team.
And he contributes to R weekly.
And so
I see that as part
of his job too.
It used to be a hobby, now
it's actually part of his job. But Sam
collects that information
anyway. But then internally,
they produce a little kind
of monthly blog post to see
what are we seeing as
the latest greatest.
And that helps enormously.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: That's
great. Any other thoughts
in encouraging your
teams to keep upskilling?
-
I'm going to say the same
thing that I did for community stuff,
which is put that
time into people's
reviews and into their weeks.
I've had jobs where it's
expected that 10% of my time is
upskilling, and I need to
be able to talk about it.
I need to be able
to say, this month,
I used 10% of my time
to do X, Y and Z.
And if it's a part of the
accountability for somebody,
then they know that
they're allowed to do it.
- Yeah.
- It's hard to write--
back to also what
was said earlier that
your focus on your day job
to get stuff done and off your
desk and out the door
means that it's hard to
assign time to learn.
I was just thinking there that
we have people who learned base R
15 years ago and they haven't
even got to the tidyverse yet.
And then we've got other
people who learned the tidyverse five
years ago and
aren't aware of the
most recent changes
to functions.
And so you've
got to keep that
ball rolling and continuous improvement
and just kind of keep chucking
it under people's noses.
- I like the ideas of
actually putting it on your calendar.
I see, Tony, you mentioned
you're encouraged to use
two hours per week upskilling.
I've been thinking
about this with--
I talked with our
president yesterday about sometimes, I
have a tendency to want to
focus on a lot of things and a
lot of different ideas
and making things better.
But it's also important to
pick what is the
most important thing
that I want to focus on and
trying to block a whole day for that
just as dedicated focus time.
- Tony, I think--
do you want to add
something there?
- Yes,
it doesn't always happen.
But if you can have that goal
and maybe put two hours on your calendar,
especially if you have
a remote work day
and can avoid having
meetings during that time.
A lot of times,
it seems hard to do because
of the immediate needs,
the fires that you
have to put out.
But
it can pay off in the long run
because something could take a lot less time
because you've already got
that baseline of knowledge on
whatever skill it
is you need. So
it's definitely worth it if you can find
a way to fit it into your schedule.
- Definitely. And George, I
see your hand's raised too.
- Yeah, I wanted
to share my latest
tip or trick for
upskilling. I'm going back to the old
days of using RSS feeds in my Outlook.
And something that
you used to see back in
a long time ago, '90s and early
2000s, so now I get our bloggers
and a lot of other
resources sent directly to my Outlook
application. And
every time you see that
little number saying how many unread
messages you have, I know like,
OK, there's another article
I'm going to keep up with.
And that's been really,
really helpful for me lately.
- That's a great tip. Well,
I know we are a
little bit over on our
time here. But thank you all
so much for jumping in the
conversation today and being
the featured leaders here.
I love to see all of this.
The chat happening as well.
And I'm excited to
go read that later.
But thank you all again so
much for joining us here today.
And I wanted to let everybody
know that next week,
Joe Chang, our CTO at
Posit, will be our featured leader.
Joe is the creator of Shiny.
And that will be the
last Hangout before
our summer break.
So we'll be off from
Hangouts for July.
But we'll be back the
first week of August.
So yeah, next week with Joe
Chang. Hope to see you there
too. Bye, everybody.